okay sure we know he was using a little
gizmo to make sure the air is breathable
and whatnot but this is still a name
actor takes off his mask for the
audience cliche meanwhile his buddies
D'Angelo and Marx get the film from
behind and rarely show their faces
because they're going to die soon
treatment all heroes in these movies
need their cliffhanger moment when they
totally don't rescue someone early on so
that they will be extra motivated for
when it's time for their comeback it's
there Eminem gets destroyed at the rap
battle moment with more deaths and we
won't have this ridiculously contrived
hatred for each other that will provide
pointless verbal sparring later in the
film have you done how is it that nobody
knows that the submarine blew up right
after they left grooving Jonah's right
wouldn't the captain of this rescue boat
say hey guys good call on leaving when
we did that submarine blew up right
after we left in case you confused it
with Shanghai Costa Rica also in case
there was any confusion as to what
market this movie is targeting a whole
minute of this helicopter taking off and
landing with eleven cuts showing us
different angles of the helicopter and
flight I hear you get hairy palms if you
do too much copter bation forget that I
could give - that's what this research
station is called I can actually read
the big bold letters located on the
fucking research station and don't need
the giant subtitle at the top of the
screen but good to know we're 200 miles
off the Chinese coast I'm sure that
factors in somehow because nothing sells
shoes like putting them on Rainn Wilson
hyung-jin can we stop with this bulbs
please a person who tries to speak
another language but says something
completely nonsensical and makes a fool
of themselves all your base are belong
to us but he just said actual words
according to the subtitles so she should
have understood all of it even if the
order of those words didn't make any
sense would you learn how to pilot a sub
cut there
wide a cut and here this is one goddamn
sentence sorry about being triggered on
something like this but damn was there
something in her performance that they
had to cop when if she was talking on
screen did Michael Keaton rig a stage
light to fall on one of the actors so he
could hire it with Norton and it
happened right there was the editor
trying to make a scene like I was in a
shark's mouth while watching this movie
it could be a completely new world and
what if you're wrong then you have
wizard 1.3 billion dollars funny line
and everything but this guy really throw
a 1.3 billion dollars at a Rhys
project without knowing what they were
trying to do Laurie because we don't
know the dates on the other side
seriously
they sent three people down in this
vessel to go through a previously
uncharted section of the water why not
send something remotely to take a few
pictures and samples first Origen
recommend an immediate right turn three
five zero could be a landslide that's
how I check landslides don't make
90-degree turns Margaret Court would be
amazing at cinemasins
one could do that do the roamer I don't
think I wanna know hey maybe it's time
to go back up to the surface you know
avoid the big thing that did that to the
whatsit we've gone 5,000 meters 8,000
meters at some point it just becomes a
number I mean it's a number that
measures the depth to which at some
point you'd internally combusts due to
the atmospheric pressure but semantics
from the helicopter
we must go to Thailand good go John it's
not like there's a timetable for the
survival of your crew how long did they
have maybe 18 hours of course Jonas
Taylor is a drunk now that's the only
dramatically acceptable condition to
fallen hero can be it go worse than he's
a heroin addict and the movies gotten
too dark take away his addictions then
that person isn't anguish enough about
the time he killed his friends why can't
these people ever be working some
blue-collar job and living a normal life
when they're needed again the Angela was
an asshole anyway you drink too much and
now you're only saying that because I
literally never beer in my hand you
always happy in your hand you know why
because I drink too much that's a
conversation that happened it's Laurie
your ex-wife and her crew are trapped
below we live in thousand meters and we
could just live with that but we wanted
to wait until you told us no so we could
play a garbled audio recording because
we're definitely not on a timetable also
I guess it's lucky for this grooc that
Laurie just happens to be Jonas is ex
wiping why does there always have to be
a connection by the way this does
nothing for the movie other than forcing
Jonas to come to the rescue and Laurie
basically does nothing for the rest of
the movie I feel that I owe it to my
crew to give this rescue of the best
chance of success and that best chance
is someone who is a heavy drinker that
hasn't dived in five years and probably
has serious psychological issues related
to diving
trivia there are other Jason Statham's
out there we got a candlelight Oh these
assholes just remade deepstar six didn't
they remember kids always have freshly
applied makeup and a high ponytail
before attempting any submersible vessel
dives so my life's in your hands
pretty much that a problem no delay -
really no way you're dying she does oh
it's because she's hard isn't it
you must be the crazy guy kids I dads
what the plot is
and Taipei according to screenwriters
every time a husband cheats on his wife
and runs away with his mistress it's
with the Pilates instructor it's 2018
it's time for more mistresses to be
chemical engineers he's doing a black
gap this fucking guy that might as well
I called this character dude who came
from his mother's womb bitching about
Jonas because that's really his only
character trait sure he doesn't
about-face after this mission but he
ends up getting eaten by a shark so but
just a minute ago Ruby Rose said he's
diverted all non-essential power like
heat and life-support motors when she
was asked why Jonas was going so fast so
if he's already diverted the power from
the heaters to do that how much more
power does he have left a divert I've
got visual I'll get word is he more
fluent okay they're alive how do you
know that just by looking at the ship
also we already knew this because Heller
said he still had access to their vitals
which is way more important than your
visual confirmation of the ship on the
ocean floor as big as the shark is how
is it possible that no one can see it
until it's right on top of them and yes
yes I know the sense of being a squid
but she should have seen that as well
Deus Ex Meghan uh I guess the Meg just
wants to wait for a moment that will
serve as better dramatic timing when it
attacks because it's probably been done
chasing flares for at least a couple
minutes I'm gonna make an argument at a
point here she would be so happy she was
rescued she wouldn't even care this is
her ex-husband does anyone remember that
she also has a screwdriver stuck in her
stomach can we be like Jeffrey Pelton
The Hunt for Red October and dispensed
with the bowl tow she saves the others
by sacrificing himself and that's pretty
noble of it but my main issue here is
what the fuck is the shark attracted to
if there are no lights and no movement
slow motion Statham shower naked
nobody has different definition of naked
than I do you should have some clothes
yep original plan nothing like a little
post colleague was eaten by a shark
flirting to get morale back up to speed
male gaze the neck goodbye the welt in
half roll credits living fossil living
fossil 8 my friend technically that
living fossil charged the origin and it
exploded your friend but I'll forgive
you because you're distraught so why am
I still adding a sin I don't know so did
everybody a headquarters fall asleep at
the wheel when this giant 25 or so a
meter shark approached it is there no
radar and wouldn't this caused some sort
of breach alarm I think I heard this
place was built for 1.3 billion dollars
so damn well should that a minute
later when the evolution came up the
temperature increased by 25 degrees char
could come right through there
this movie is telling us that the Meg
could only come up through the lair if
the temperature shot up by 25 degrees
and a huge pop one of this movie is that
Jonas encountered a large sea creature
just like this five years ago and
another rescue attempt but what happened
back then to allow the Meg to shoot
through the lair remember this is the
first time the lair was ever breached
that's the Megan need to get there now
or call the Coast Guard it's absolutely
ridiculous that these scientists plus
the billionaire all go out to engage
with the Meg when it should be a bunch
of rescue experts like Jonas it's like
the rescue effort requires all the
characters we've been introduced to in
the film regardless of their actual
rescue experience these sharks have no
fins that's because their hats are like
shark fins they're clearly in no
condition to be wearing hats all
football soup looks like the Meg even
the score the Meg for the revenge this
time it's personal
unfished in all this lets get yourself
at least the Meg is nice enough to pop
its fin up to let you know exactly where
it is somehow we have to give this boat
next to that make no we can't it's
already proven aggressive towards boats
except this one because it knows you
need to come up with a plan first also
it's not like the other boats we're
trying to get next to the Meg either
right it just attacked them so why do
they think they're safe as long as they
keep their distance to a prehistoric
shark that ate our friend I guess you
need a common man who subs in for the
audience but this guy's constant
bitching yelling and poorly timed humor
will instantly make you forget that he's
a trusted member of a scientific team
it's a major disservice to his actual
skills by not giving him anything except
this to do the entire movie before
sending out their movie wants us to
believe Jason Statham can outswim a
75-foot prehistoric shark not sure if
I'm sitting that over the fact that I
might believe the movie I mean it's
Statham this movie is so dumb also why
did the shark stop pursuing the boat
it's definitely as fast as this boat and
it clearly has a hatred for boats what
an asshole
this thickness it would take 20,000
pounds per square inch are we talking
about breaking that's eight to nine
hundred thousand yeah but the Megalodon
is a shark that they know very little
about
it's a shark that can apparently break a
whale in half it left noticeable bite
marks in their headquarters glass like
Joe Piscopo is gun and Johnny
dangerously it shoots through schools
and while it does prove impossible for
even the shark to break the cage how the
fuck do you really know until you
studied it
hundreds of shuck dice I like this and
she knows this right I get that soo-eun
is a badass but this whole time she's I
feel like they're just going up against
the tiger shark I'm not a big fucking
prehistoric one can't figure out why at
this point they are surprised by
anything other than the fact that
they're all terrible and unqualified for
their jobs and stupid ridiculous shark
movie decides not to go full ridiculous
and give us an entire scene with suyin
trapped in the shark's belly while
inside the indestructible cage now he
can't get the scene where Jonas comes up
with a plan to jump into the shark's
mouth and MacGyver some contraption that
will cause it to go full on Linda Blair
and shoot Suey into safety and we would
have seen the shit out of that but it
would have been fun also aren't these
people highly qualified scientists you
mean I had no idea that the shark could
have swallowed the cage you know how
huge this fuckin thing was and this was
the day Jonas his hand was shredded into
a million pieces from the cable oh but
he's still getting dragged along that
makes sense get the out of the water
Savior thank you for later Louie goes
through a lot of trouble to trick you
into thinking soo-eun is dead when she's
this movie's only viable future wife for
Jonas remember the bite marks nope and
Jonas shouldn't either
unless I missed his bit about getting a
degree in shirk dentistry you can use
this as your date in that big speaking
of Toshi wasn't he this guy's best
friend I understand they just cheated
death and beat the shark this guy's
acting like he's gotten to the it's fun
to joke about silly phase of his
grieving process already and this guy's
totally dead by the way in all of my
time watching movies I haven't seen a
guy this swallowed by a shark before
actually getting swallowed by a shark
also looks like this movie is going with
the same plot mechanism is Jaws they
caught a huge shark but not de shark and
Richard Dreyfuss will be here to show us
the Louisiana license plates it also
also there's another med fine but how
did it know exactly where the baby meg
was
look I'm all for comic relief but this
comes just after their friend was
swallowed whole and the shark is still
out there it's like the Meg appreciates
levity and allows everyone to get some
humor in before all the killing I'll
remove 100 sins if it turns out that
John wakes up with amnesia and discovers
he was trained by Treadstone okay you're
a good person man everybody in this
movie is a sacrifice hole work Toshi
su-eun and now Heller it's as if nobody
wants to save themselves in this thing
also after this I guess the shark has
done eating Jax doesn't swim back until
after Heller is eaten so his sacrifice
could have amounted to absolutely
nothing good thing these vibrations
don't attract the Meg that was literally
right by them second
seriously what comes down to it John's
life will be remembered for the peace
treaty he brokered between apples and
oranges sometimes things happen then
change your life forever ruby has time
for this it's not just about the once
looks great I came here to celebrate
with you I'd remove every sin we've
given this movie if a shirt came out of
nowhere to eat Rainn Wilson right now
just like the one did 2 samuel l.jackson
a deep blue sea not the meg but the
exact same shark that ate samuel
l.jackson and people who see every
person that gets maimed or killed by
that thing is a potential lawsuit a
potential casualty even if I were to buy
that which I'm not sure I do especially
with this being international waters and
all then why didn't they actually
contact the Chinese government and make
it their problem like he said he did a
few minutes ago this is possibly the
worst moment of my life worse than
Expendables 3 home front or the fate of
the Furious yes yeah it probably is I
think we killed a whale it's right below
us one of the chances a whale would just
be swinging around in the exact spot
that the Meg was swimming also wouldn't
that whale either a have gotten the hell
out of Dodge as soon as it knew it was
swimming with that thing or be already
been killed by the Meg yes
Norris never Coolidge didn't call anyone
was he thinking I wanted to make this go
as quietly as possible yeah but do you
know he died do you know he went out to
bomb the shirt oh you're telling us is
that he didn't call him yeah what a dick
but there's absolutely no indication
they were told what he tried to do and
whether he died doing it it might be a
silly thing to nitpick but several times
in this movie we don't know if the
characters understand certain things and
it removes context from their actions
shiny black what's that oh nothing it
only has some of the most densely
populated beaches in the world
I guess the Meg enjoys the chapter on
beaches in the Old Farmer's Almanac just
like the rest of us Peter starts shot
sounds goddamn Frank or okay but hear me
out maybe don't tell the authorities
it's a prehistoric shark maybe just tell
them a very large man-eating shark is
out there and try not to bring up
prehistory or Halla notes during the
conversation lion the unholy fuck of off
kingdom is soohyun's daughter coming
along for the ride
she doesn't even do anything stupid that
saves the day how long until the shock
is to those people 20 minutes I'm not
saying they couldn't get all this set up
and to where they need to be in under 20
minutes but I'm saying there's no way
they could get all this set up and where
they need to be in under 20 minutes this
dog jumps into the ocean God knows why
he doesn't even join the party of
swimmers and paddles way the fuck out of
the water for some reason I'm guessing
to finally be free of its owner also dog
is in trouble in a disaster movie cliche
pipin survives this look I'm not saying
it's impossible that everybody would be
using swim rings when they swim in the
ocean and maybe it's a law in this
country or something I don't know but
how can you enjoy the water with this
kind of ring traffic not sure how old
this kid is supposed to be but I'm
guessing he's over this popsicle is
going to taste like when it gets salt
water on it years old I've got this
theory that movies like jaws and the meg
were created as revenge fantasies for
people who never got to go on vacation
because seriously this guy look I'm just
saying I'd be gone like I wouldn't rely
on the others to tell me it's gone I
just never get into that water again
ever
but these people now why ruin a
perfectly good afternoon simply because
of a shark scare this movie's never
really figured out what the mag really
is attracted to like at first it was
lights then it was boats
it was wild movement in the water like
every other concurring in the world and
now he's bypassing all the free food to
attack the boy in the plastic bubble
it's all fucking what you mean aside
from the mass deaths that just occurred
it's safe to go back in the water I feel
like it might be a faux pas to say it's
okay after 35 people just got eaten by a
shark like it might be the two soonest
too soon ever too soon why is this
perfectly aligned grouping of people on
floats till this far out the Sharks give
up on the easy kill just to go after the
wheels that are making noise either way
this is whale sounds volume 2 ex machina
[Music]
kids did the mick can perform a sneak
attack on jonas because it looked like
the meg performed a sneak attack on
jonas i'm ready to fire take the shot
are you telling me that the scientific
research team was given underwater
vessels with missile firing capabilities
doing this you ugly busted car won't
start in a horror movie cliche reason
number many why you shouldn't have
brought this girl on the boat
this works ah the magic of movies will
never question how an expert of deep-sea
diving rescues manages to make all the
right moves in this unique situation
scaping his damaged underwater vessel
finding a way to ride along with a
vicious shark while it rips into it and
getting the perfect amount of time to
aim at and stab the Meg in the eye to
win the day and live to tell about it
also going into the movie you think
there's no way that will actually give
us Jason Statham by himself in the water
going toe-to-toe with a shark and then
they give us exactly that while I give
the movie credit for this David vs
Goliath moment doesn't make it any less
stupid so my hands are tied
sure this is an ex machina but I'm
wondering how su Yin managed to locate
Jonas in the middle of this feeding
frenzy and target one shark out of the
hundreds to savor they couldn't even see
the Meg itself under the water a few
minutes ago wait they were saved by the
Love Boat why are they even still out
here didn't they supposedly see it eat
the dog did the shark just pass up on
the boat after the attempt on the dog
how long can a dog swim in the ocean
after we last saw him thirteen minutes
have gone by an actual time the events
that took place after this definitely
took more time than 13 minutes so can
dogs swim for that long the fact that
they ever put this dog in danger in the
first place this movie for that but that
it survived double this movie we're
gonna fuck later coffee puns also though
I've got two words for your movie and
the first one also starts with that
are those shirts with laser beams
attached to their heads what have you
done but if my brothers don't shake
hands
brothers gotta welcome to the old level
I might be showing her my Oh face we're
good to go we're not gonna make it
if I could eat you know feel really bad
I'm hiding you're gonna damn it oh now
wait a minute I did have a chubby kid on
a raft earlier today you didn't hear me
when I said very important this morning
what good are you do you have a brain do
you want to keep this job you work
literally in the middle of the ocean you
think serious black actors my age can
just to throw away jobs it's all a
business now they got us you're doing
Pinter off-broadway besides I like the
cold thirty years later I get a postcard
I have a son